hey everybody we're back with another
installment of ask dr. Mike series with
the amazing Ricky Dillon hello here we
go alright this one's a little weird and
kind of embarrassing weird is something
I'm very accustomed to Sparkle okay Kara
juice does not make your eyes sparkle I
sweat easily and a lot and okay yeah I'm
sweating right now I'm always sweaty
whenever have any heightened emotion at
all my first response my body's it's
just sweat yes so I can be excited I can
be nervous there's a huge variety in
people okay of how much they sweat it's
really genetic I cannot sympathize with
you more look we film YouTube videos
right so when we're filming YouTube I
have to take breaks and at times fan I
was gonna say a hair dryer and blow the
master head I'm like this outfit covers
it up from fine right now the reason why
we sweat is a because we're hot
obviously that's an easy one be because
we're stressed and nervous or see our
metabolism is high so you say like you
lose weight if I maybe loves exercise so
you probably have a higher metabolism
Ellie sweat is it not smelly sweat and
what's funny about is when you're hot
and you're like running and playing
sports right generally that's what's not
supposed to smell because that's thermal
regulation the ik temperature regulation
okay
sweat but then you have sweat like that
nervous sweat or high metabolism sweat
where it's released by different sweat
glands called apocrine sweat glands a
smellin kind and know that it has more
protein in it that the bacteria that
live on your skin actually eat it and in
the bacteria release that smell
basically bacteria parts that is crazy
so when someone has Bo they actually
have B F bacteria farts Wow there are
clinical strength deodorants you can use
and a lot of people have tried them all
nothing work I have a I have a hack for
you
life hack alert try putting on na
deodorant antiperspirant at night
listen of runs deodorant is just the
smelling like the gel but covers the
smell okay but antiperspirant is usually
the white one that actually ought to say
to stop the sweat try putting on the
antiperspirant before going to sleep at
night because it works
better when you're on a cool body
temperature at night you're generally
cooler when you're sleeping and it'll
plug your pores so when you wake up in
the morning cuz it works for 24 hours
you'll won't be a sweaty on to the next
one let me check my notes I can't have
anything touched my eye or like foreign
objects around it I can kind of deal
with it but like if you were to right
now just try and go around my eyes with
water and I when I would stop when I got
him tested for the first time they did
that weird machine where they like poke
your eyes I did you have my body like
four weeks out I guess I started seeing
spots then I completely blacked out and
then I woke up and threw up office oh
it's that serious I guess my question is
like do I have a phobia or let's start
here like what's a phobia fear is a good
emotion because it protects you from
dying if there's a lion hanging out over
here and we have fear we hide and we
live because of the lines but when your
fear is at such a high level that it
disrupts your life and it's not in
proportion if I have a fear of fuzz
being on the couch that fear is out of
proportion to what that fuzz can cause
danger rational fear yeah
the difference is mine is I don't my
mind fine like when I went the doctor
flower that was completely normal like
oh whatever and then it my body like
shut down sit down but I'm never like
scared when you were little did you get
hit in the eye and think so it's unique
in the sense that usually if like I
would start talking I could get in
closer you would start like getting
nervous
see I can't like have to no it doesn't
so he has like a physiologic phobia
physiologic just means something that
your body does yeah obviously your
body's controlled by your brain so it is
a brain thing it's just not an emotional
thing I have crazy I've on to the next
one another one another myth I pee all
the time
like a lot like a lot like no don't
worry but I also think a lot of water
too okay I don't have it spite habit or
I'm not like dehydrated so the aunt
might be like healthy it's not I was
gonna say so the answer lies in the
color of your pee you have white you
have clear pee white oh it's white pee I
don't clear pee or very dark yellow
almost or it's not like that so it's not
it's not super clear you know what
horses eat right
Grethe no they draw oh hey sure yeah hey
forces or did too
that'll be really matching forces don't
each strong whatever straw is found in a
horse pen okay I don't know four horses
live hay straw that color okay I like
light yellow golden color that's the
best color should I be concerned that I
pee all the time
what's all the time how excessive like
once an hour you don't pee once an hour
like okay say I have a shoot somewhere
in LA like 45 minutes away I'll have to
pee before I leave and then when I get
to have to Amelie pee again
are you nervous it's like a joke for me
whenever I show up for sure you're
nervous
my manager knows I have to pee right
away once that time you had blood work
that would be a good well start like
with my I I pass out like a blood taken
like from my what if you don't look what
if you just do this I've tried that what
happened to the pain it's the same thing
with my eye I what happens my body I
pass out that's okay I can draw blood
when you pass out this part of my arm is
like my eyes too I'm a mess the way the
whole body works is it's always a
balance between two nervous systems
sympathetic nervous system and
parasympathetic pretty easy sympathetic
is what happens when you see a lion when
you get excited when you get nervous all
those feelings power sympathetic is the
opposite it's like laying resting
digesting that kind of thing when you're
running from a line your body doesn't
want you to think about peeing right
because you're running from the lion
so it'll distract you from peeing but
then as soon as you jump into the
relaxed state and comfortable state your
body's like oh now you can pee and it
reminds you that you need to pee so if
you're constantly bouncing between those
two nervous systems you might think that
you need to pee but really you're not
peeing that much yeah well I got hey
when I go it's nothing a lot yeah so
it's probably bad okay probably but get
a change I mean yeah all right that's
more dramatic than my night thing it's
like pretty but it's a slower pass out
if you pass that you'll come back you
need someone fun to do it like I do it
fun I have fun okay you know like
parents do that they airplane thing with
food I do say anything with the needle
oh my god
I've once passed out or like my face
went dark
when people were taking blood for me I
can't even like look at you doing I
don't know why there's one good thing
from this you're never gonna become a
heroin addict this is intense but good
what do you think about support workout
supplements okay I'm very passionate
about
yeah I know I could tell her hey Zack
can I like bring one the ones that you
yes please oh no I'm sorry did I break
it
sorry I've tried a bunch out and some I
don't like some this is new I'm just now
my aggro Knight reflects and just
actually another one of my questions was
I'm always wanted for my my testosterone
levels are low okay
maybe since I can't gain muscle well
enhance of it okay this so actually
belongs in a specific part of your
kitchen and that's the trashcan okay if
I make a bottle that looks like this and
I put salt in it and I put whatever
ingredients I want into it in my house
slap a label on it
I can now sell it in GNC no one checks
it when Consumer Reports which is a
really good magazine that does Studies
on what's nonsense what's BS they found
that 50 percent of those supplements
didn't even have the things that were
they stated here's my problem as a
doctor we pride ourselves on
recommending things that are based on
research clinically studied testosterone
enhancing complex clinically studied
means they paid a few scientists to test
on like five people yeah to see if this
works okay that is not a good way to
test anything you have one left fire at
me okay I travel a lot for my career and
stuff love it it's great but I'm trying
to awesome get sick a lot when I travel
and I think it might be for a few things
I think one maybe like the long airplane
ride it's like people just grow sitting
in there but also I go to like colder
areas a lot and I'm I live in LA so I
don't usually have thicker coats I don't
know is there a reason why I'm I get
sick more often you think so a few
reasons for and you hit some of them
completely on the head that was really
good okay I kind of impressed number one
when you're taking a long airplane ride
the air is really dry on the plane so
gross
so it dries out your mucus membranes and
that's where a lot of your protections
inside of your nose the air is recycled
so all the germs that people write using
their there everything you touch has
been touched by thousands of people
before and they likely sneezed in their
hands also when you people travel it
throws off their sleep schedules they
get jet lag if you travel to a cold
place a lot of people say oh being cold
doesn't get you sick and technicality
they're right it's not the actual beam
coil that gets you sick when your body
does to protect the heat to keep you
warm
it pushes blood away from the outside of
your body and push it
the inside of your body okay keep your
organs warm but when it does that it
pushes the blood away from the nose and
it from away from the mouth and it
pushes away also all the white blood
cells that protect your body from
infections plus the air is drier in the
winter so viruses hang around more in
the air people spend more time inside
during the winter because I'm cold
outside so they're in closer proximity
so you share all the viruses so all
those things people do get more sick but
just netted off through F of like a
20-hour flight yeah that's all I got I
to 20 hours yeah I got sick from that
Fla what's your favorite place you've
been to I love Hawaii I've never I also
love Japan I've been there the same with
MELAS I feel in school oh my god you've
been everywhere I travel but he's Tommy
you've been to Greece no I'm gonna go so
bad I want to go to tend I want to go
really bad I hope you learn something I
honestly really did yeah and if there's
something that you have a medical
question on leave it down below in the
comments we had a lot of fun on Ricky's
Channel we're doing a really funny skit
I'll be sure to put that in the
description box and click on that to see
the video stay healthy stay happy see
you next Sunday she wants to go outside
go squeal
Oh piggy I like eating grass too
[Music]